ever go into a movie and think to
yourself this movie's gonna be so
horrible I'm just gonna tear it apart
then you don't actually hate it it's
actually not that bad exactly The
Sorcerer's Apprentice I can't do special
effects try to have fire alright so I
was expecting this movie to be like the
worst of the worst I was expecting
Sorcerer's Apprentice to make Clash of
the Titans look like Amadeus
surprisingly I didn't hate it actually
kind of enjoyed it here alright so the
story goes Nicolas Cage has to train
that kid from she's out of my league to
be a Sorcerer's Apprentice to be exact
all the while having to stop Alfred
Molina from opening up one of those
little Russian nesting dolls yeah this
one has that chick who played the Borg
Queen inside not good if she gets out
end of the world okay so like I said
this movie surprisingly good what I
liked about it was the magic the magic
was actually explained to be like
science I mean in the movie they
described magic as being science like at
the molecular level like the apprentice
has to wear those old man shoes because
Roberts old shoes they block his current
you need that current to sling some
magic and to make fire you make the
molecules go faster and heat up and then
boom fire and since they use 100% of the
brain they can do that and that's pretty
much how magic I mean would work if you
really think about it I mean was just a
cool angle to play magic like that and
brought some validity and cool points to
the movie props to that and the
characters were pretty good I mean
granted they're not original I mean it's
not like you haven't seen these
characters a hundred times over in
movies but they weren't bad
I mean Alfred Molina he played a good
bad guy but he always plays a good bag I
mean you can take Alfred Molina and put
him in something and you automatically
have a good bad guy I mean it's not like
a deep villain in this movie he's more
like a Disney villain although he is a
Disney villain so there you go and The
Sorcerer's Apprentice that kid from
she's out of my league he plays the same
role in this that he plays in everything
happy and said he's really good at it
although I'm calling [ __ ] on his
characters love lives I mean she's out
of my league Sorcerer's Apprentice the
guy who's scoring all the hot blondes
how he looks like me with AIDS a
stereotype skinny white nerd I salute
you that being said you can also go to
hell
Nicolas Cage let's face it the guy was
like a hero ten years ago and lately his
career has been kind of a joke and he
actually wasn't bad in the movie but
maybe because his character wasn't too
deep it means no Dumbledore Gandalf he's
no Dumbledore or Gandalf skids but for
some messed-up reason it just kind of
seemed to fit this time now that being
said if you hate special effects you're
gonna want to tear your eyes out in this
movie this movie has a lot of them and
one of the disappointing things in this
movies Alfred Molina kind of picks up
this chrony along the way like his
apprentice but not really as apprentice
and the dude was totally underutilized
like I liked it
you seen this guy was in he just wasn't
it enough and it's not a deep movie I
mean it's pretty straightforward good
guys bad guys young romance magic there
you go
so it's not actually like a [ __ ] box of
a movie I actually had a surprisingly
good time with it I actually got I've
enjoyed it makes me think I have a brain
tumor but what can I say I mean there's
no Pirates of the Caribbean but it is
vastly better than a lot of the [ __ ]
that's come out this summer I'll say
that for sure so you have two days to
see this movie until Inception comes out
just steam rolls it makes it absolutely
obsolete because who are we kidding but
I mean this is way better than like
Clash of the Titans or Prince of Persia
sands of time or you know movies like
that to try to shoot for what this movie
shoots for there it is but if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more than click right here to see
more